Oh, my God.
A woman records what appears to be a live
cow being pushed by a bulldozer.
On that bulldozer?
Yes. He's alive.
She was filming from public land.
The farm owner drove up and confronted her.
You cannot videotape my property from public property
Why are you concerned about being filmed
if you have no problem,
you think this is a legitimate business?
It is a legitimate business.
Utah prosecutors charged the woman with
“agricultural operation interference.”
Am I free to leave or am I being detained?
You’re being detained.
But she was on public land.
They dropped the charges several months later.
[Cow mooing]
But what if she’d sneaked on to a farm
to record what she considered animal abuse?
More than a hundred such investigations
have been done.
Activists pose as farm workers
and secretly record the way animals are treated.
An animal rights group released this
undercover video of the dairy farm.
It shows workers hitting,
kicking, and throwing young calves.
We are not showing the most disturbing parts
of the video.
Farmers, upset up about these recordings,
are persuading politicians to
essentially outlaw these undercover investigations.
The controversial Ag-Gag law
the sixth state to pass an Ag-Gag law.
There are activists stalking farms to try to capture
something that the public doesn't understand.
Kay Johnson Smith speaks for a farm group
that supports the ag-gag laws,
though they don’t call them that.
We would call it farm protection. Farm protection.
What about everybody else?
Why do you get special protection?
The agricultural community is the only business
community that this sort of tactic
is really being used on right now.
I'm an investigative reporter,
I can't do my job if there are laws
that prevent me from showing things.
Nobody believes it if you don't see it.
These activist groups want
to eliminate all of animal agriculture.
Brittany you’re holding a dead body
This group livestreams its protests on Facebook.
You saw a dumpster with hundreds of dead birds?
Many of the activists stormed into the farm.
Some stole some of the baby ducklings.
We were just able to rescue almost 30 baby ducks.
Others chained themselves to the entrance of the farm
[Music]
Later the activists released this video of
the 30 stolen ducklings, adding music,
and showing the birds running around, apparently happy
[Music]
They stole these ducks after seeing this earlier
undercover video of injured ducks at the farm.
Mercy for Animals says their undercover investigations
have led to criminal charges.
Ag-gag laws often prevent such investigations--
which is why farm states pass them.
A bill making it illegal to apply for a job
in a farming operation under false pretenses.
But what about free speech?
Ag-gag laws chill speech.
Lawyer Amanda Howell speaks for the
Animal Legal Defense Fund, a group that says
ag-gag laws are unconstitutional.
And they did get several states’ laws struck down.
Iowa, then, just passed a new law.
Ag-Gag 2.0.
A bipartisan bill trying again to stop people
from lying to get onto farms.
These groups are exposing issues that are happening.
If they really cared about animals,
they would stop it right then.
Instead, they go weeks and months without reporting
anything to the farm owners.
That’s true. This investigation went on for months.
Agriculture groups now are pushing laws that would
force activists to report abuse quickly. Why don’t they?
They want to make their movie.
They want to make their sensational video.
It's because they care about the animals
that they want to show that that's something that
happens every day on these farms
Consistent, constant, abuse
A company can say, "This is a one-off."
This is not just discrete actors. This is company policy.
They say they don't want to just correct
the abuse on that farm.
They want to change all farming practices.
What they really want is to stop people from
eating meat, milk, and eggs.
Do you want people to stop eating meat?
I want people to act in their conscience.
But you didn't really the question.
Do you want people to stop eating meat or eggs?
I think that… again … I… I...
[laughs]
Are we asking... sorry... Are we asking me personally or
asking the Animal Legal Defense Fund?
She never did give a direct answer
Workers in a turkey farm abusing the birds
Animal rights activists have exposed things
that need exposing.
Wal-Mart now taking a stand when it comes
to the treatment of farm raised animals.
How else would you have made these changes
without sneaking into your farms?
Well, that's to say that farmers can't be
trusted and I think that everyone-
And in the past, some could not.
There are bad apples in every industry.
However, I would say 99.9% of farmers in America
They do the right thing every single day.
Farming isn’t always pretty.
[Farm sounds]
People have some right to privacy, no?
I think we should all be worried when corporations
are supporting laws that impinge our right
to free speech.
We should worry,
whatever you think of the activists,
and I have problems with many of them,
government shouldn’t pass special laws
that prevent people from revealing what’s true.